[Music]
thank you
always have been
always will be
[Music]
welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host Paul and why is Loki a bad
Gardener hey cause he's got too much
time on his hands so wait wait where are
you going come back come on no seriously
I've got plot leaks I've got plot leaks
made come come back so the new Loki
season 2 trailer has just dropped online
and it actually confirms a lot of
different leaks that we've had on the
show which could explain what's
happening in the new look throughout
this video I've compiled lots of
different things from a ton of scooper
accounts have been dropping rumors and
leaks on what's coming in the show these
might not be true so take them with a
pinch of salt but I think once we get
into it you'll see a lot of this stuff
lines up either way huge shout out to
Daniel rpk my time to shine Josh at
denim nerds can we get some toast and
trust me bro 18 for posting this stuff
over the last couple of months not gonna
waste any more of your time and
according to trust me bro 18 the ending
of season 1 actually misled a lot of
people from what the user said Loki
isn't in an alternate TVA and he's
actually gone back in time to its early
days this is in a time in which Kang
ruled over it and it's before he created
the timekeepers and became he who
remains he hadn't erased everyone's
memories and was still clearly the
leader of the TBA presenting an imposing
figure with his monuments and statues
rather teaser we see stuff like the
mural depicting the multiversal war with
all the kangs on it and this is actually
showing the past and the story the main
one gives to TVA this was of course
reworked in the Miss Minutes video that
talked about the timekeepers doing it
showing how the past version has what
really happened Loki has been sent back
to this point but he begins slipping
through time which is something that
isn't supposed to be able to happen
great to see you guys
[Applause]
wow time slipping were you times you
know that yeah you've seen that yeah can
you fix that no
it's impossible to time slip in the TVA
I know but we just saw it happen
yeah he's thrown across multiple points
in a Time stream and then Mobius takes
him to RB played by kihu Kwan this is
someone who according to the leak
spelled all the tva's technology and his
use as a way to stop Loki from time
slipping Josh explained this as being
when someone exists in multiple times at
once but with the TVA existing outside
of time and space it shouldn't be
happening here so the first episode it's
basically going to be Loki experiencing
multiple versions of the TVA at
different points in time I'm just
speculating here but I'm guessing this
is when he sees himself reading a manual
which may be a future or past version of
himself now pay close attention to
what's on the screen during this bit and
you might notice as a sort of hourglass
thing in the middle of it this seems to
be pulling the multiple timelines
together and it's putting them into one
single strand now going off the leaks
can we get some toes posted this is
something known as the time Loom which
basically takes together all the
different timelines and puts them into
one manageable thing we discover that
the multiple timelines be being created
at the end of season 1 has overloaded
this and it's now having difficulty
pulling it all together now as we know
once a timeline was created Kang started
wiping out multiple points of the
Multiverse and after all this was
organized he wiped everyone's memories
and became he who remains later on in
the trailer we see Loki destroying a
mural of the timekeepers and in the
center of this we can see them holding
the time Loom you also get a shot of
Mobius when he's in a sort of space suit
and then catch him walking along a
walkway which is to the time Loom itself
this is a giant device that we can see
he's pulling everything together and we
learn in the season that this has
actually been damaged this is why Loki's
slipping back and forth and the main
thrust of the early episodes will be
about fixing it now this idea of the
time Loom and timelines Feathering away
also ties in with the record that
service is falling apart if you cast
your mind back to quantumania Yo we'll
go back don't think about modox but but
think about that senior where we go to
the probability storm and you can see
this effect happening to a giant version
of Batman this effects also carried
across to the monitor later on which has
missed minutes on it thanking them for
their service this is the TVA coming to
its end and thus they have to put things
in place to stop this from happening all
these moments show that the time streams
being deplaced and thus Mobius has to go
on and fix it which brings everything
back together at the moment the
Multiverse it's kind of pulling itself
apart you the can constantly jumping
back and forth between timelines and
thus they need the loom to rain it all
in the loom is also said to be what
stops incursions from happening and it
means that timelines are kept in order
instead of just being out like random
threads and we also get a shot where
Loki appears in front of a store that
sells jet skis huge announced to Paul
mackley on Twitter for pawning out that
this looks like it's Ace Cafe in Wembley
and just some speculation here but I
think this might be where Mobius was
before the TVA scooped him up man of
course loves his jet skis like you love
hitting the thumbs up button and it
could explain why he has that
subconscious desire to ride one up into
the sunset it either way the leaks say
Loki tries to expose the truth about
Kang which is when he destroys the mural
and reveals Kang's face it's kinda like
that scene in Ragnarok where hella
reveals the truth about Odin but this
obviously happens later on in the
timeline rather than when Kang's ruling
the organization now we obviously know
that he meets several versions of Mobius
as well because the one at the end of
season 1 knew about Kang whereas in the
quantumania post-credits scene he had no
idea who he was this was post-memory
Erasure hence why he didn't know what's
going on whereas the earlier visions
that we meet will be well aware of who
he is now according to the leaks obi's
gonna be the one who gets to the bottom
of it and he helps Loki out by teaming
up with Mobius he's the one who gives
him the battery which we can see in a
scene where Mobius holds it and he's
also the one that provides the space
suit so that it can go and do the walk
the time loon itself is gonna get fixed
but it's still gonna remain a big part
of the Season we actually see this later
on in the teaser and it's what Victor
timely is presenting at the show that
was given to us as the quantum credit
scene in that timely was talking about
time and how it's possible to shape it
time it shapes our lives but perhaps
we can shape
it now in the trailer we see the curtain
at this show being pulled back and you
can see the timelyman stage as the
central piece now on our trailer
breakdown we mistakenly say that Loki
and Mobius traveled back to 1901 to look
for Victor timely I don't think that's
right though and as many of you pointed
out there will Colombian Exposition
happened in 1893 from what I've been
told that is Sierra it's going to be set
I just said 1901 because that's the air
can travel back to in the original
Comics either way this will be as early
as before he spawned the TVA and fully
mastered the time Loom they'll be seeing
his origin story which is why we also
see a prototype Miss minutes later on
that goes wild on the people in
attendance at the fair Kang is obviously
from the future so this is why he has
technology like this and he's travel
back in time to then build timely up
around him that's a town of timely in
Wisconsin it's also got his name so yeah
lots of things going on there that we're
gonna see the internets of now ravana is
meant to Bubba then as well and she'll
be coming off the back of leaving the
TVA at the end of season one this is
just me speculating yeah but I think
she's gonna be trying to find out things
about her past and how the TVA was
formed you also get a shot where it
looks like she's in the void and judging
by the purple glow I'm guessing this is
a life now according to the leaks though
the main villains getting promoted as
being Kang that's not actually the case
he'll play more of a secondary villain
role and we'll actually learn that
there's someone else working behind the
scenes there'll be strange TVA agents
appearing that are trying to attack Loki
and the next part of the season will be
about finding out who these are now
according to the leaks this will lead
lokia Mobius to go after a guy named X5
who we actually see at several points in
the trailer the rumors stayed he'll have
used the chaos at the end of season one
to go back to the 70s Daniel lenov
shaped himself into a famous film star
in the teaser we see the premiere for
his movie zaniac who's actually a niche
character from the comics that the film
will be about and the teaser also has
Loki grabbing and interrogating him
which is when he starts tapping into his
powers of mischief and just going wild
this includes his green blasts and he
also duplicate himself in order to
restrain him later on X5 is apparently
taken into the TVA unlock your sense of
interrogating him there this is when
he'll tell him Sylvie's working at a
McDonald's and from this point Loki will
visit her and find out what's going on
and all this stuff was posted by trust
me bro 18 back in December and knowing
what we know of the trailer it makes a
lot of sense so Sylvie according to them
will basically have left the castle
because she's unable to deal with
everything and can't handle being a god
Loki's gonna convince her to join up
with him and they're then gonna go and
try and fix everything and this will put
them into conflict with the other
versions of the TVA and it's at this
point we start to learn who the actual
villain is now this is something we
talked about in our trailer breakdown
the other day but every plot leak I've
managed to find from a reputable Source
also backs us up now they're apparently
gonna reveal in the show that it's
actually a feature older version of
Sylvie who's the one sending her TV8
agents back and she'll be played by the
actress Kate what we learn is that Selby
ended up taking control of the TBA again
and this caused further chaos and a
splitting of the time stream she
realized that in the past she'd messed
everything up so she was sending back
her TVA agents to stop the prior visions
of herself and Loki she just wants to
simplify everything like how he who
remains had it because she's realized
it's too difficult to manage all these
variants and these alternate realities
it just ultimately leads to Wars and
incursions because people like Kang and
Doctor Strange will constantly jump
across to different realities through
either their technology or by
dreamwalking so Sylvie wants to Reign it
in but I actually think this series
might end with her death they could
realize that he who remains was a sort
of better the devil you know and that he
managed things well enough to the point
that they just allow the natural cause
of time to put him in charge there's
also the possibility that Loki could end
up taking over the role and that he'll
be the one who looks over everything I
have to hammer home now these both these
last bits yeah they're pure speculation
and we might even end up with the old
selfie staying in charge as she who
remains or potentially the young Sylvian
Loki will decide to rule it together at
some point in this past though this old
Sylvie will have to have carried out
what the young one did which is push
lokiao and then kill he who remains
Selby probably realizes that's all a
mistake and she might finally come to
terms with the fact that she has to
either rule it alongside someone or just
step down either way that's all the
leaks I could find that seemed to build
off the back of what we've been shown in
the trailers and knowing this hopefully
helps it make a lot more sense obviously
I'd love to hear your thoughts though so
make sure you comment below and let me
know do you think the leaks are real do
you think they're fake yeah comment
below and let me know please drop a like
on the video as well make sure you
subscribe and if you want to support the
channel as a member of the spoiler
Society then please click the join
button you'll get early access to videos
every week and it goes such a long way
to helping a set if you want to get some
heavy spoilers merch we've also got our
t-shirt line located just below the
video that will let you pick up all
kinds of tops like our Theory time one
house the dragon stuff Marvel teas and a
lot more we drop new designs on there
all the time too so definitely keep an
eye out for them and yeah thanks for all
your support now if you want something
else to watch we've actually got a
breakdown of Guardians of the Galaxy vol
3 on screen right now carried out by
none other than my main man Mt guys now
come over to the heavy spoilers Channel
he's joined join the bad guys and yeah
he's going to be doing breakdowns like
this from time to time so yeah
definitely keep an eye out but out of
the way huge thank you for sticking
through the video I've been poor let's
see you next time take care peace